SILVANO LUCIANI:
Hi, everybody.
And welcome back to Google+
Developers Live.
I am Silvano Luciani, and I'm a
developer programs engineer
for Google+.
JOANNA SMITH: And I'm Joanna
Smith, and I am also a
developer programs engineer
for Google+.
And today, we are here
to talk to you about
Google+ Platform Insights.
SILVANO LUCIANI: Yes, the goal
is to get you fully set up to
learn as much as you can about
your app from these extra
analytics for Google+ Sign-In.
JOANNA SMITH: Exactly.
But first, we want to take a
moment to really talk about
what are Google+ Platform
Insights.
SILVANO LUCIANI: Yes,
good point.
As mentioned, Google+ Platform
Insights are a set of Google
Analytics that are specific
to Google+ Sign-In
functionalities, such as
the Google+ Sign-In and
interactive posts.
JOANNA SMITH: So for the Sign-In
button specifically,
we have two different things.
You can compare your total
number of users against the
number of new users for
a given time period.
And then for an interactive
post, you have the ability to
track the viral spread of
a post through multiple
different metrics.
SILVANO LUCIANI: Yes, we provide
data on the number of
interactive posts published,
post views, clicks,
clickthrough rate, and on-app
install clicks.
JOANNA SMITH: Exactly.
And then, because it's Google
Analytics, you can look at all
of this data over a period
of 30 days or over
a period of 7 days.
And you can also break it down
by platform between web,
Android, and iOS, which gives
you the full ability to track
what your users are doing and
where they're doing it.
SILVANO LUCIANI: And to get
access to all of this data,
the first thing that you need to
do is link your + page with
your project in the Google
API Console.
To do this, we have
instructions at
developers.googl
e.com/+/features/analytics.
JOANNA SMITH: Exactly.
And these are the instructions
that I'm going to follow and
show you today, so you can
follow along if you're
interested.
But to get there, let's take a
look at our documentation.
And so if you're exploring the
documentation in general, you
can find these instructions
through the left nav under
Features, Insights.
But what we have here is we
have a lot of information
about what Google+ Platform
Insights are.
And you can learn about the
different metrics that are
available, and also some ideas
of what they might mean for
you as a developer.
And at the bottom of the page,
we have set up instructions.
And they're very specific.
They're very clear.
And you shouldn't have
any trouble.
But if you do, be sure
to let us know.
So the first step is just
to get the + page ID.
And you can do that from
the + page dashboard.
So to find this dashboard, you
can actually click on the link
there, or you can find it from
the left nav within Google+
and click on Pages.
And you'll see every + page
that you are a manager of.
So this is my test
page for today.
And what I'm going to do is
I'm going to click on
Connected Services.
And this takes me to a page, and
I can see that the Google
APIs Console is one of
the options already.
And if I click Start, this
is how I'm going to
find my + page ID.
So you can go ahead and copy
this to your clipboard.
And then if you're interested,
you can click through the rest
of the wizard to see what the
next steps are going to be.
But I already know the rest of
the steps, and I'm going to
show you, so let's skip
ahead to that.
So within the Google APIs
Console, which we've taken you
to multiple times, there
are multiple tabs.
But for today, all you need
to worry about is
the Overview tab.
Because all we care about is
this Google+ Page field, where
you can request a connection.
And all you have to do is
paste in the + page ID.
But we are Google, and we care
about security, so it's not so
simple as just having an ID.
You'll see that this
says pending.
And what that means is that you
have to go back to your
dashboard, go ahead
and refresh the
Connected Services tab.
Let's find it.
So go back to Connected
Services.
And you'll see that now we
have this API Console.
And it will have the name and
the project number, which
aren't terribly descriptive,
but yours will be much more
indicative.
And it's requesting
an approval.
And here, I can approve it.
So we have a two-way mutual
approval street to really
protect your app.
And so what happens now is if we
return to the dashboard one
more time, we will see that the
Platform Insights button
has replaced the Connected
Services tab, which has moved
into the More field.
So it's easy for you to get to
your insights very quickly.
And now we have no data for me
because it's a new page.
But you can break it down by
feature to see what's going on
between total users
or new users.
Or switch to interactive
posts.
And maybe I only care about
the non-existent web data.
SILVANO LUCIANI: Yeah.
So at this point, as you can
see, you can start learning a
lot about how your
app is behaving.
Unfortunately, Joanna's demo
page doesn't have any data.
But we are sure that your app
will be far more interesting.
And we are sure that Google+
Insights will be a valuable
resource for you.
JOANNA SMITH: Exactly.
And so the other thing we wanted
to mention today is
related to an announcement that
we made this morning.
And if you're watching this GDL,
you're probably already
convinced of our many different
value propositions
for Google+ Sign-In.
But this morning's announcement
just is one more
reason to really strive for a
deep integration with Google+.
And what we talked about was
we announced our app
activities integration
with search.
So you can really start to see
some of the Google+ data that
you as a developer get to write
surfacing within search.
And what this means is that
using Google+ Sign-In is more
than Google+.
It's a gateway to Google.
And when you write data, like
app activities, you are
writing that data not just to
a user's profile, but to
Google so that we can surface it
in interesting and creative
ways across all of
our products.
So this is just the beginning,
and we're really excited to
see what this will mean for
you as a developer.
SILVANO LUCIANI: Yeah.
And to find more about it, go
check the announcement on the
Google+ Developers Blog
at googleplusplatfo
rm.blogspot.com.
JOANNA SMITH: Exactly.
SILVANO LUCIANI:
Now, let's see.
No.
We don't have any questions
for this episode.
So if you want to learn more
about Google+ Platform, you
can find more details in our
documentation site at
developers.google.com/+.
And also, remember, if you have
any questions, please
reach out to us in the
Google+ developer
community on Google+.
JOANNA SMITH: Exactly.
Or you can use the Stack
Overflow tag Google-plus
because we check that every day,
and we really like to be
able to answer your questions
and help you.
And then of course, if you just
want to learn about the
product, and maybe get started
with tinkering with it on your
own, you can see all of our
language examples at
github.com/googleplus.
SILVANO LUCIANI: And last but
not least, if you find a bug
in our APIs, or you have any
suggestion or feature request,
use our issue tracker.
Please, file requests,
file bugs.
And also, star the bugs in the
feature requests you agree
with because we use the star
when we triage the bugs and
feature requests every week.
JOANNA SMITH: So I do.
I triage those every week.
So please star things that
are important to you.
Because that will let me know
that the developers think that
issue is important.
So that's everything that
we have for you today.
We hope that Platform Insights
really help you out.
And thanks for joining us.
SILVANO LUCIANI: Bye.